[Music]
hey there my name is manuel canelo and
i'm rafael canelo we're actually
brothers and we live here in alberta
canada
we do a lot of things together
and this time we decided to take a
course in devops from simply learn the
course proved to be very beneficial for
both our careers yeah i got a promotion
after the course and i got hired with a
new company
i'm actually a mechanical engineering
graduate and i've been working at my
company for the last four years
in 2020 i came to know that my company
was starting the hiring process for a
devops infrastructure team
at the time i was working as an
implementation specialist and my
colleagues recommend that i take a
course in devops if i wanted to be part
of the team so i started doing my
research and then he came to me saying
that he was also looking for a devops
course yeah funny enough i actually
found the course through instagram but
you know my situation was slightly
different i have been working as a
geomatics field technician for about
four years but i wanted to change my
career into something that involved more
programming and automation so when i
came across with this course i said you
know what let's take it
and caltech's name was definitely a
deciding factor
in july 2021 we got our certifications
and i immediately posted that on my
linkedin profile you know coincidentally
in november of that same year we got the
good news
and i got hired as a gis developer
which has allowed me to do way more
programming
which is what i wanted to do
around that time i got promoted to the
devops infrastructure team and saw a 21
salary hike
the overall course was awesome but the
part that i enjoyed the most was a
docker certification training you know
what i also really enjoyed the docker
certification training i think there
were brothers after all
yeah
the experience was amazing and being
able to study together was definitely
very nice yeah it brought us back to
those good old days when we were going
to school together